Looks like The Washington Post
might be zeroing in
on the person who leaked the Top
Pentagon documents on social med
The Post spoke to
one of the alleged leakers onlin
Online. Friends.
And he says a leaker posted
hundreds of pages of photos
of classified U.S.
intelligence in private group
and a private group on Discord.
It is a platform
that's popular with video gamers
Now, the friend says that the us
who is known as Ogg,
indicated that he brought the do
home from his job on a military
O.J.
claimed that he spent some of hi
inside a secure facility
that prohibited
cell phones and other electronic
that could be used
to steal secret information.
I was first made aware
of these documents.
I want to say about six
to eight months ago,
I was in a discord server
by the name of Doug Sager Centra
And in this channel, there was c
documents being posted by a user
who I refer to as OG from this p
The documents were often listed
as Ukraine versus Russia first.
However, it
slowly spiraled into just intell
about everything.
So the Post is reporting
that OG took
hundreds of photos
of the actual documents
and shared them with the group,
including detailed charts
of the battlefield
in Ukraine
and highly classified satellite
National security reporter Natas
Bertrand is at the Pentagon with
Natasha, this is an unbelievable
to read.
He had been posting them for a w
The folks there didn't believe
that it was actually real.
And the friend says
that there were Russian users
in this online group.
Yeah, John,
this is really remarkable report
So what we are learning
is that the
alleged leaker of these document
was someone who works at a milit
according to this friend
who was on this server with him
and had been posting documents
for months and months in this gr
that did include
foreign nationals,
including according to this frie
Russians and Ukrainians,
as well as other people
who said
that they were from Eastern Euro
It is not clear at this point,
of course, who this leaker actua
He is only being referred to as
and the friend has refused
to identify him at this point
because they say they are
they are aware that the FBI is u
a very intense leak hunt for thi
But they know where they know
his real name.
They know where he lives, they s
and they know
that he works on a military base
where he can have access
to all of these documents.
But look, in terms of of what
this group actually was
and what kind of bound them toge
It appears that they all had a l
according to this
this friend here of God.
The military guns here
is part of what he had to
tell The Washington Post.
He was that
he was a
young, charismatic man who loved
God who loved shooting guns
and in racing cars.
He did see himself
as the leader of this group.
And ultimately,
he was the leader of this group.
And he wanted us all to be sort
super soldiers
to some degree and form to fit w
well-armed stuff like that.
So originally, according to the
the leaker, alleged
leaker was actually hand transcr
these classified documents
that he was bringing home
from his work every day.
Ultimately, that became too tedi
according to this friend.
And he actually just started
taking photos
of the documents themselves
and posting on posting them onli
And those are the documents
that CNN and other outlets
have been reporting on for the l
or so
that has spurred a massive inves
across the federal government
for this allegedly occurred on N
Let's talk about his intentions
just to keep his friends informe
He wanted them to be informed
about what the government was do
according to
his friend who was on this chat
It appears
that he was motivated
by a very dark view of the gover
He was not necessarily
motivated by, for example,
being in favor of Russia
or being in favor of Ukraine.
He was motivated instead
largely by conspiracy theories.
And he had a very dark
view of the intelligence communi
and the military writ large.
And he wanted to show his friend
kind of
where taxpayer dollars
were going in terms
of the intelligence community,
what the military was doing.
And of course, the kind of suppo
that the US
has been providing to Ukraine.
He wanted to keep this group up
to date on current events.
And one of the friends did say
that they were always impressed
by how ahead of the news he seem
So obviously this is going to pr
a lot of fodder for law enforcem
And of course, the Pentagon
who have been turning over
every stone to find this guy, Do
And it's just the beginning
of figuring out who he is.
Director Clapper,
this is so stunning in so many w
and buried
in this reporting
The Post reviewed about 300
photos of classified documents.
Most have not been made public y
which means this isn't over
and there's more to come.
What's your reaction
Well,
it's not good, obviously, Poppy.
This is a pretty serious thing.
And I think
when I first sort
of reporting about this,
I wonder
how much more is yet to be revea
and some of which
you know, could be quite serious
So for somebody who spends
a whole life in intelligence
is pretty disturbing.
According to the post OIG,
claim that he spent
at least some of his day
inside a secure facility
that prohibited
cell phones and other electronic
So if they prohibited it,
that it also prohibits
people who work there from print
How does this leak happen then?
Wouldn't you know?
Or aren't people searched
or what have you
when they're leaving the facilit
to make sure they aren't carryin
these documents?
Well, Don,
the system
that we
have is is only based on persona
That's why there's an attempt ma
you know,
we use a fairly rigorous
clearance process
to ensure that people
who are granted access
to such classified information o
aren't are trustworthy
and are not going to expose it.
So that's that's the weak link h
And tightening up
administrative procedures,
which is understandable
and the feeling is it's
got to do something.
But really,
the concern here is as people an
if they are bent on on exposing
classified information,
they'll figure out a way
to beat the administrative proce
And that's that's the real issue
I thought this is striking
that his friend
who talked to The Washington
Post said that OGE got upset man
because people weren't
paying enough attention
to these documents that he was p
So he changed his tactic
rather than spending time
copying documents by keyboards,
he took photographs of them
and dropped them into the server
and sort of
he had to make his followers
pay attention to this.
It just sat there
for months, ignored before
You know, that's probably this o
And reading the article
really struck me that this sneak
if that's who
it is,
has in common
with his previous legal predeces
Aldrich Ames, Robert Hanssen
and Edward Snowden,
a degree of narcissism here
where there's an ego element, th
feeling self-important
by having access and exposing
such material.
And then in this case,
being irritated
because people weren't
paying proper attention
to a at all,
to all the effort
to purloin these documents.
So that I found that striking
and something in common
with his predecessor leakers.
As you were reading
the information
in The Washington Post,
I'm wondering
if it gave you any insight
into who this person could be,
what their role could
be at this facility.
I
actually not, Don.
This could be anybody.
I mean, the system is set up.
So the people who need to have a
to such classified information
and there are a lot
can have ready access to it.
And so
it appears that at least in the
we're going to clamp down on
on the dissemination of such mat
which is always the knee
jerk reaction after such a revel
And over time,
those procedures will prove to b
and inefficient and they'll be r
So I don't
I can't tell because this could
a very senior person
or someone who's relatively juni
who simply had administrative ac
Yeah.
Well,
we do know they were driven by c
because The Post reports that,
you know, OGE was telling his fo
the government
basically set up the massacre
at the Buffalo supermarket
to increase funding for for poli
So sort of
hooked them
with a parent conspiracy on this
was called Thug Shaker. Yeah. Ye
Thank you, Director.
Always a pleasure. Appreciate it